thank you very much I'm very honored to
be here so well yeah I'm going to speak
about the business model of media I
think it's important for you to
understand with what is my vented
vantage point I'm a journalist as a
training and now I'm a head of digital
for a major media company in France
which is the main business news provider
and what I'm doing is I'm trying to turn
around the company and and that's why
most of my experience is at this time so
very too quick slide as far as the media
is concerned and most of the print price
is concerned here is what it looked like
before the Internet nice comfortable
apparently indestructible sedan and now
this is how it does look like right now
so basically if I had to sum up my talk
it will be these two slides ok more
seriously how did did we end up here
first of all we have a change in the way
that news our consumer news are read I
understand that the word consuming news
does not appeal to everyone so for lack
of a better word you have understood
that you will have to endure my to
endure my bad english so and the second
thing is a kind of new definition of
news the whole concept of news has been
totally revisited in the last year
another important component is the
failure of of advertising basically the
digital advertising for news is a
failure it doesn't work and lastly media
lost the the technology battle they did
not invest enough question is can good
information survive the digital tsunami
I think the answer is yes but there is
some restriction and we are going to
have a look at it the first one is the
big change and the new relationship to
news and all news has changed let's
rewind the tape a little bit the good
old days for print publishing was
roughly this one that I could have used
more recent newspaper of course at this
time we had one product very Freddie
spread for well very simple we are to
reading times morning and evening now it
turns out that the English paper as
mostly disappear but there is there is
still plenty of morning newspaper as we
speak a straightforward leadership means
that we are addressing one population
which is clearly identify this
population doesn't have very that much
choice and they read the newspaper we
present to them which is pretty simple a
top-down production and that's as a
journalist is a very important thing
because one of the most destructive
force of the internet for journalists is
the feedback I've been raised in
newsroom in which in which we were used
to basically decide in the morning what
will be good for the readers to read and
they fought back thanks to the internet
and I think is a very good thing
it has totaled a lot of good things to
us and a cozy competition at the time
newspaper media of all sorts we are
competing again each other now there is
there is a different picture news is
consumed is read on a PC it's fair on
smartphone it's right on tablets in
sweater it is read on ear adores this
platform these vectors they do have
their dedicated product which is going
to be website mobile site application
closed application open application web
app or app by Apple and stuff
encapsulated editions digital editions
newsletters are all sorts of alerts and
push notification to the feed up as
feeds Facebook page lyndie ebooks we
have whole whole bunch of new
application for a photo for further news
and each of them are different business
model we are the free which is ad
supported I will come back to that later
you
paid for per day per copy per article
you have all sorts of subscription
monthly weekly you have passed to to pay
for your content you have flat fees you
have netted system like pay waltz you
have payment in kind Google is
experimenting a very interesting way to
have people paying without paying for
news I will come back to that later
maybe and you have sponsors sponsored
pass those on sort of tweet you have
lots of things so there is also
different
primetime if you take in the black
drawing here is the the web consumption
from different time frame as well as
mobile mobile is it slightly differ from
a country to another but sometimes it
could become contrast cyclical you will
have different use at a different time
if we take the the basic pattern of the
digital conception of information here
is how it look like in the morning you
will have newsletter application
encapsulated editions maybe sometimes
ebooks in the transportation at work you
will have website in the afternoon as
well you will up some website but
slightly less at 6 p.m. in the evening
at least is for a European so you might
give or take some sort of some stuff but
you will have again ebooks and the
evening you will have ebooks website a
video tablet and stuff and if you take
the the vectors the the platforms you
will have a competition permanent
competition a permanent overlap between
platforms readers PCs sorry it's not for
a smartphone
IRRI doors and tablets and it's going to
mix up all the time so it makes things
very complicated and above all you will
have a permanent stream and a permanent
access to Facebook Twitter and various
kind of alerts so that makes the
environment extremely complicated to
deal with we have multiple audience the
audience had never been so fragmented we
have this audience during using
different devices with specific
expectations for
or different moment of the day and that
and that makes us to think about for
instance as a media publisher should we
have some kind of day part programming
like television means serving different
content for different hours on a
specific device I don't know if you
realize the complexity we are in from
the first slide with the single
newspaper for a single public now we
have to encompass the whole this whole
image one thing about the free model
because unfortunately for the publisher
I represent here the Internet is born
with the idea that information should be
free which I don't think is the case
let's look at some facts a newspapers
such as the New York Times spend 200
million dollars per year for its
newsroom they maintain 1200
reporters and writers of all sorts and
just to give you another example when
they are covering a big war such as the
earrin war the era not yet here on the
Iraq Iraq war or the Afghan war they
they spend something like three million
per year that's the cost of maintaining
relatively safely assets of reporters
photographers videographers and stuff in
a capital such as Baghdad or Kabul
they cover for instance they they they
spend for instance seventy million to
cover international news news is an
increasingly costly business when you
run a newsroom you are spending money
many times in dead ends you will have to
you must be in a position in which you
will allow your reporters your journal
is to go okay you have a clue we believe
there is a story here let's spend you
you are free to spend days weeks with
your team and stuff and it might be a
dry hole
if we don't have such liberty we won't
have original reporting that's a very
important point of course it depends
when you what's your definition of of
news because news as change drastically
in the meantime there is a big split of
news and basically there is the news as
split in three parts
the first one I would identify is what I
will call community news it's the news
that which is a big word is immediate
it's free there is no economic value
we'll all get the same news at the same
moment typically it's going to be the
Baghdad the the
Boston attack for instance which will
show up on every media at the same time
this is the domain for portals news
portals such as Yahoo this is going to
be live blogging for values outlets the
second element is social news in social
news it is basically the echo-chamber
the notion of accuracy is completely
secondary the most important notion is
rather reverberation of course that's
the kingdom of Twitter Facebook or stuff
like Reddit with all the things we have
seen recently especially in the Boston
case in which the wrong people has been
single out on on Reddit and the third
one is what I will call the quality nish
it's basically for the utterly rich
educated people it's a very small market
but those people have the advantage of
acknowledging the value of original
reporting and that's for newspaper
magazine size and stuff and most of them
are doing fairly small audience of
course there is some some exception
we'll see that later so for a news
company we are facing kind of dilemna
which is should we go of should we look
for large audience of qualified audience
there is audience driven site they are
built for clicks they are aiming at
large audience but they don't have any
royalty their CPMs the the the revenue
is extremely low
they are enabled since they don't have
any loyalty to actually gather
subscribers and they are highly
vulnerable arable in terms of economic
accident economic condition on the other
end of the spectrum you will have
qualification driven website they are
less dependent on traffic smaller
origins but they are they do have higher
Lt CPM is much higher and they have a
better monetization because they can
diversify the source of their
monetization through advertising
targeted advertising high quality
advertising and subscription and they
are much they don't have the same
sensitivity to the economic condition
they are much more resilient if I draw a
little picture you will have here let me
use the clicker so you will have there
is an exception which is the New York
Times the New York Times and some of
this newspaper some of this kind they
have they will have a large audience and
they will have a large a fairly high
revenue per user but that's mostly the
exception most of them are in this
category curiously enough the Guardian
which is an excellent newspaper online
they gather a very small amount of a
fairly small amount of money they have
something like 16 million unique viewers
per month and they only only collect
something like 50 million dollars per
year which is fairly small if you
compare to the to the New York Times for
instance mean that there are food their
average revenue per user is extremely
small but there is worse of course you
have publications such as salon or slate
which are great from a journalistic
perspective that they don't bring money
they don't bring audience and they are
struggling and they're being struggling
for years and of course there is some
specialized publication such as the
Financial Times or The Economist which
is by the way the same group more or
less and they command
slove relatively small audience
relatively speaking but they will have a
higher higher arto so let's go to the
advertising thing basically like I said
advertising is not working and there is
four reasons for that first one is bad
creativity basically the credit
creativity on the advertising sucks
another thing is the endless supply a
huge inventory
another thing is unreal and reliable
analytics and the force element is crude
buying practice let's have a look and
I'm going to have a drink in the mean
time that's what's for the first world
way by the way because there is other
wave coming creativity this is just an
example of a fairly good website oh um
it's about women of course but look at
that this the site has been entirely
boat by Gagne which is a beauty kind of
a product outlet and they entirely owned
the the visual of the site and it's more
frequent than disappear and then the the
identity of the site has been completely
diluted that's kind of extreme example
but it just show you how far the
advertising communities is really is it
a ready to to go because of the
advertising visually doesn't work very
much many newspaper online newspaper are
looking for what I call the Zen option
if you take the New York Times which is
the current version of the New York
Times and this time I took the dining
and wine section on the web it's a bit
confusing especially if you look at the
broad page you have advertising almost
everywhere and look at the new version
new version is really different and if I
take side by side the different pages
the current the actual one and the
future one which is going to be online I
guess before the end of the of this year
is totally different and Lamone for
instance is doing the same when you take
lumen which is roughly the equivalent of
the news of the New York Times at least
they see themselves that way because I
don't think that there is an equivalent
to the New York Times on a Mon for
instance they have clearly two zones in
their offerings you have free when you
access the newspaper for free you will
have pages loaded with advertising
loaded with a lot of stuff and when if
you happen
to be a subscriber you will have a
completely different site and if you
click on a birth button which is called
then it will show article with just bare
minimum you won't have anything else so
there is clearly an issue of a UI issue
in that in that respect reason number
two is endless supply each day thousands
of new millions of new URLs are created
by by media company my own newspaper
Lizzie Co is creating something like 300
to 400 new URLs per day
the New York Times once again is
creating more than a thousands of URL
per day and these URLs are competing for
the same Bible but they are completely
for the same competing for the same
marketplace so we are in this absurd
system in which we are creating an
unless supply of half content that's
totally the the contrary of television
for instance television at least on the
French market
you basically have 300 slots per day
it's limited every day whatever the year
the demand is so the price are
functioning the demand and supply system
and they are able to maintain a fairly
high price so the concept of endless
inventory is an extraordinarily powerful
deflation engine
the result is CPM basically fall fell by
30% in roughly four years you have to
keep in mind that in France major
newspaper high-quality newspaper are
selling as a CPM for something like six
euros and it will used to be 10 or 12
euros a couple of years ago and my own
newspaper is selling for 10 on average
it's because it's a specialized
newspaper Plus marketers since the day I
don't
trust the performance of the adverts I
think they are asking now for proof of
performances so this reason number three
is very inadequate measurement
techniques the paradox is just amazing
the Internet is born with all possible
measurement on a native way logs and
stuff you know that better than I do
still we are stuck with a Windows panel
such as this one Nielsen is probably the
worse because Nielsen is the is the de
facto standard for advertising and guess
what
how Nielsen was able to be the de facto
standard for advertising that's very
simple and Nielsen would people who are
extremely clever and I must acknowledge
that they do that they are doing their
best in order to correct the flaws in
their system but they basically go to
advertising agency by media buying
companies and they say look we have
being measured
we have been measuring television for
quite a while and measuring the internet
is just going to be the piece of cake
you will have the same instrument the
same interface and stuff so let's go for
it
so the whole industry the whole
advertising industry is now relying on
such kind of off panel the reason number
four is what I call the Ken and Barbie
syndrome is the buyer she is the seller
or it could be the other way or the
other way around basically they are
commanding the worst-possible
transactional practice ever they are not
trained they completely ignore all the
data we publisher try to give them means
we are making lots of analyzes about our
sites who is watching our news and so on
and so forth and they only buy by the
bulk only nothing but volume and
discounts so there is some hard figures
coming to that if we take this to
newspaper for instance and if I could
apply some kind of very gross scale the
revenue between the print edition and
the online edition would be roughly that
way with this incredible figure for $1
gained in digital advertising newspaper
and magazine I've lost 16 dollars on
print pad try to build a business model
with that that's that's an amazing
that's an amazing data look at this
curve you have the newspaper advertising
revenue in million of current 2012
dollars and here you have major plunging
and we are basically at the same level
than we were in the 50s and online in
red is not changing that much so we are
facing a real a real problem here but
there is more
remember the Canon body okay so the good
news is there will soon be replaced by
machines okay but is it really a good
news what we call programmatic buying
real-time bidding etc or ad networks
automated transaction platforms they
hold started with good intention the
idea was actually to sell remnant
inventories by the bulk are a very
inexpensive price and being able to
retarget this advertising to the right
people the problem is now they were used
to sell in if you have a page of the
webpage the way that we were used to
sell the bottom of the advertising now
they are pushing up and there is a great
deal of premium spaces which are
actually sold now on a real-time bidding
system it's totally out of control
in 2012 we represented 13% and now it's
in 2016 it will be about 30% which is in
my view the rope who will be and ways
seems the CPM are down to a fraction of
a dollar or a fraction of a euro we are
facing a massive massive
deflation stuff by the way people at the
New York Times feel the same this guy
mark Franz who is one of the head of
digital up there
he said that ad networks have led in a
shift in ad dollars away from classic
display ads to what real-time purchase
that are driving down rates and this
semi disintermediating news publisher
and speaking of news publisher the guy
knows quite a bit here is an interesting
map this is basically all the partners
we are facing when we are selling
digital advertising for a media and you
can you can I don't if you can see that
but they are all here you are the
agencies the the the remaining
advertising agency you have the media
buying platform they basically decide
what kind of when a product is issue who
is going to what media are going to be
purchase you have the DSP the demand
side platform you have the Ad Exchange
you have the horizontal ad networks you
have the vertical ad networks you are
people who are targeting companies what
targeting audience you have companies
which are monitoring performance you
have companies which are specialized in
mobile stuff and you have hold the whole
data company including especially
Facebook which is a heavy data provider
you have data optimization company they
are all here so this is most of them
most of them are bottom feeders which
raise a serious problem for our economy
well like if it wasn't it was not enough
there is another wave which is the
mobile the one is fine because everybody
is flocking to see to watch news on
mobile problem is roughly we have now
many new site they have 30 to 50 percent
of their traffic coming from mobile but
it generates five person at most of the
advertising revenue the real figures
will be more like three percent
thirty to fifty percent three to five
percent terms of revenue just give you
an idea on yes well that is that there's
not the real estate available for the
ads on the phone or everybody puts their
thumb at the bottom edge to block out
the answer
oh it's basically it's basically people
don't like advertising on mobile what
number one point number two the creation
is just ugly I mean the stuff I showed
on the webpage I mean on a mobile device
is much worse it's much more intrusive
especially since on the mobile stuff
you're going to read your stuff in the
public transportation system in a kind
of urgency way where your attention is
not at its best
and trying to capture the attentions of
the people's attention with advertising
is quite is quite challenging and the
thing is we are also facing a drop in
the CPM because when we are three to six
or maybe ten sometime on the web we
might be below one on on mobile and
there is a sign that even Apple failed
on the mobile advertising with is I ad
program look at this interesting chart
it's for the is for the French market
but I I take it the same for therefore
the American market of course the
advertising revenue coming from mobile
is growing fairly well it's growing six
times better in France than the web
advertising revenue our are doing but
the audience is growing twice faster
when you count in visits and three times
faster when you can in page use it means
that each people who is flocking on the
mobile for us brings structurally less
and less money over time which is really
a really serious problem okay to sum up
sorry
sure
what you what nooks it would be
convenient if you got the same revenue
per user in the sense of yeah yeah sure
to be great but it doesn't cost you any
more to set things up right it's all
automated
yeah but except that you have a clear
shift in terms of audience that now the
audience is transferring itself to the
mobile mean that the audience is
transferring is is is going to a
platform in which we make less money and
these it doesn't regardless of the price
of serving a page on mobile we are
making less money per user on mobile
much less money per user in a mobile
than we do on on the regular web so the
problem is not that you're making less
money per user that it's the you while
you're getting more more users
it's the users are transferring from the
web to mobile it's both actually because
because I mean in an ideal world we
would like to be able to make the same
amount of money on both on both platform
that's why we we are I will come back to
the later but we need to rethink their
advertising basically in all platforms
available so a good campaign and I'm
anticipating a little bit but the most
successful digital media news digital
media companies such as the New York
Times for instance they are selling
campaigns on all platforms print but
also at the same time web mobile tablet
and the idea the best idea is actually
to grow up in the food chain and to be
able to conceive campaigns which will be
able to take advantage of the same of
the of each platform that's that's the
plan because otherwise if we are in kind
of one-size-fits-all we might have a
very lousy lousy system Dennis you're
suggesting that
ability of the user to advertising is is
growing less and less particularly in
the mobile area oh no no no I'm such as
you know I'm not suggesting that you
mean the susceptibility I mean yeah user
don't like advertising on my wife they
rejected that and they don't pay any
attention to it by not looking through
and that's yeah that's not that's an
issue when we do surveys they send back
an image they send back their feedback
is extremely negative but I think your I
think your data probably is not as it
doesn't show things as bad as it really
is because the Mobile's of the past were
very tiny screens these are fairly large
screen computers with lots of capability
and multi color ads so you would think
that they would catch people's attention
but they don't it catches it catches
people's attention but they and when we
do again when we do survey they
basically rejected it I mean they they
don't like it and the advertising agency
the media by buying agency knows that
and they tend to lower the price on
mobiles and and basically it doesn't
work I think your equation at the bottom
quite casual story they're really
talking about the total revenue is going
down as the ship moves to mobile it's
not per user is the fact the total there
yes the total with a 30 percent move
over to mobile and you only get five
percent revenue of that that's cool yeah
goes down yeah it doesn't really matter
whether it's well actually it does
matter a little bit because I I think
one of the shift we are facing in media
company is actually introducing the
notion of our Pugh means that we are
going to instead of thinking in terms of
silos that I have a daily I have
magazine night a radio station I have
Mobile's app I have web apps and stuff
the idea is actually to measure what
brings a user which has been somewhat in
contact with our news content so that's
why we are looking at the picture but
you're right yeah
god I want to know so can I ask so is
the lowers
CPM on mobile because of lower
click-through rate on move or I say a
lower CPM on mobile basically because
the the Wella the entity was actually
fixing the price on mobile our of the
media buying agencies and when media
buying agencies decided that based on
surveys based on analytics based on
various performance indicators that
doesn't work they pushed the price
further down so that's that's an issue
sure isn't that also because you have
it's fine demand you'd have less
advertisers wanting to buy more book if
they don't that dress that but also is
that this also includes all the mobile
apps of doing the games and all these
other things I'm not talking about use
no you're right I'm talking about use
only okay
okay to sum up basically we have a
changing notion of news we have
segmented religions we have multiple
vectors to access the news and we have
an extremely difficult business
environment with kind of durable
deflationary mechanism at work and which
translates into a huge value disruption
okay now where do we go from here that's
what I say turning around the dinosaurs
dinosaurs the price basically as we
mentioned you get it
advertising won't be able to support to
sustain quality information but first of
all person I'm not entire Dwight
Eisenhower I want to judge Peres hammer
against the cancer part of a Tyson which
is not the case I think the model of
advertising on digital is flawed that's
it but I think it could bring some
serious cash is some commission
conditions are met the first one is we
publishers we need to recreate some kind
of notion of scarcity I've been writing
for quite a while in the Monday note
that
publisher have been totally wrong by
keeping the entire inventory available
for sale at my newspaper Liz ago at the
last count we have something like 2
million pages potentially which are
available for sale which is totally
ridiculous of course it's a kind of long
term long tail mechanism but still it's
totally ridiculous
so my belief is that publishers should
consider closing down a significant
amount of their inventory when I say
significant amount it could it could
should go as high as fifty percent
thirty to fifty percent I I take we
creating scarcity seconds ideas better
analytics my personal recommendation to
my own company and it does not reflect
the management of a position of my
company but that's my suggestion
recommendation is actually to get out
from the Nielson kind of stuff to get
out for that kind of a flawed panel we
need to create some Arab studies Erik
survey in order to see exactly what is
going on on our website and we can do
that in a very precise manner in a very
fair manner just to give you an idea in
France the Nielsen panel has 25,000
panelists people who actually have a box
on their computer which recorded every
move it doesn't work on mobile or it
were differently on mobile on mobile it
did not encompass tablets for instance
or iPhone and stuff so the stuff is
completely floor and out of the 25,000
there is only three thousand panelists
which are at work means my newspaper
which is a business use paper that
people use mostly at work is basically
counted on 3,000 people and I recall
that friends has 65 million people it's
a fairly big country so the model is it
doesn't work so I think we should do
something about it the three
Third Point is basically terminating
most of the bottom-feeders I just
described earlier of course there is
plenty of highly competent
intermediaries which are doing a great
job at an elite and analyst analyzing
our market and stuff but you have a
great deal of them which are plainly is
less and the first point is media should
move up in the value chain as far as
advertising is concerned a year ago I
went to the New York Times and I
discovered that at their data is the
advertising department they have whole
whole bunch of people with great
technical skills they are basically
taking back all the technologies
interactive technologies which are
developed for the newsroom for the
animation for the 3d stuff and they
repurpose that for the advertising
market and they actually somewhat
compete against Madison Avenue by going
to the advertiser and saying guys we can
propose you such-and-such and search for
your brand here is some kind of
prototypes here is some kind of stuff as
long as we will be will not be able to
go move up individual the value chain we
might have some issues
just quickly five more leads the first
one is focused another one is data
platforms and technology and corporate
reinvention very quickly the first one
is we need to keep focusing on our core
asset when I on the early days of the
internet the publishing internet
everybody was considering that Google
might buy the New York Times Yahoo my
enter the the business the business knew
they in the news sector and so on so it
did not happen not because these papers
people were not clever they are quite
clever not because they did not have the
financial means to do so but it's a
totally different business so they won't
enter in this in this business we should
keep raising the barrier to entry making
things difficult to imitate focusing on
our original core qualities which is
original reporting analysis exclusivity
and uniqueness these are the key word
for success for I actually survival the
best French science of course will find
their way to very to quick example the
New York Times with their pay wall they
took a while because they they took
something like 18 months to develop
their pay wall but it was excellently
executed there now they know have
700,000 digital subscribers their rise
about almost 50% for a quarter to
another and the as far as the Financial
Times concern which is our model for my
own company
they are they now have more than 300
thousand subscribers and they outpaced
the print circulation and they are
extracting a great deal amount of money
sir Sunday it cost me $6 if I want to
subscribe the New York Times only
digital it's $8 if I get the bundle of
Sunday edition class or digital access
it costs me $4 yeah
is this really a sustainable business
model well that's interesting told me
something about digital subscribers yeah
these day especially the New York Times
they've got three of these New York
Times lovers but are willing to pay a
higher price for their paper copy but if
they do their math they have to turn to
be digital subscribers because it's so
much cheaper is that really
yeah it's cheaper than the paper but I
think the average revenue for each
subscriber for the New York Times is in
the neighborhood of $12 per month
because people like you I mean there is
people who are actually taking the the
weekend issue the sunday issue just to
have access to the the digital
subscription which is the best deal
which is a below below
you know $12 I think but on an average I
mean the New York Janice has been able
to add up something like 90 million
dollars per year which did not exist
couple of years before so yes I think
it's a cynical model but it has to get
it as a gain traction and plus the
payroll of the New York Times is not it
is remain extremely payments permissive
it's a membrane when you come as you
know when you come from from a social
network when you come from a search
engine it does not decriminalize you get
for free which is not the case for the
Financial Times and I have actually
another example which is a tiny example
it's see in Switzerland a newspaper
called lotto they decided overnight to
go for a paywall but they did so in in
most in the harshest way possible No
no access whatsoever as long as you are
not registered very human of stories
available and they sustained a drop of
something like 30% in their digital
circulation but they regain this
circulation something like six to nine
months afterwards so I mean the whole
table stuff and digital subscriber
subscription stuff works as soon as
there is some quality the other thing is
data and that's why we were working on
quite a lot at my newspaper think about
best technology is a passport a 10,000
pass pages passport but we don't issue
and we don't collect the first page
which contain the name and the address
and so forth of the other person we just
assign them an an ID number instead the
first phase is on the first visit we
drop a cookie
basically we issue a passport on each
visit of the site we follow the past the
pattern of usage of the people what kind
of story he or she sees and so on and we
call that we record that and we we stand
that
that's the stamp of the of the year and
we feel a profile and this profile is
match on thousands of profile will help
which will help us to define exactly who
is going to our website within we
believe that we are working with a
French company called Jacques which is
beta in Bordeaux it's a company filled
with mathematicians scientists linguists
semiology stand stuff and we believe
that in a matter of 18 months or maybe
two years we will have thousands of
profile and we will be able to detect
with some remarkable certainty exactly
who is coming to our side if it is
someone working in the industry in the
field of marketing he or she he or she
by the way you're living in
sir Bavaria which city and so on and so
forth we will be able to collect of all
of these data and after that we will be
able to serve these people with targeted
advertising in a much more efficient way
and less intrusive way than the
companies which are doing that at the
moment we will be able to set them some
recommendation engine some
recommendation editorial recommendation
so we are going to plug that to plug the
the profile stuff on our recommendation
means that someone who is going to read
an article about I don't know
aerospace if this person of the
marketing background or if this person
as for example legal background we might
be able to push this person a different
story related to the subject so the idea
is to actually increase the rate of
circulation on the website we might be
able to sell epsilon product let's say
for example that we have conference for
accountants or a CFOs because my Media
Group is doing something like 200 events
paid for events per year we might be
able to once we acknowledge the person
he is a CFO we are going to tell him ok
there is in three weeks you can register
for 50% discount at this conference on
financial accounting and stuff we might
be able to optimize our payroll
performance which is a fairly
complicated stuff payroll you build that
over the three-year period and we just
started in and last October and at some
point we will identify the person buys
by his name or her name simply because
this person will register yourself and
we will be able to connect it to connect
the person to our CRM and we might be
able also if the person connects itself
through Facebook or Twitter we might be
able thank to the nape II I system we
might be able to have more data about
this person so basically like I say the
idea is to raise the
our music can you talk a little bit more
about how you assign the idea the
beginning is that through the user
registers no no we dropped we drop a
cookie and this cookie this cookie will
have just an idea and this idea will be
in a database and the and the data
database under the name the number of
this other person will be fed with all
its usage pattern it will be match
against model status statistical model
and we be we will be able to determine
to determine the profile of the person
no we know they don't have to register
at this time they just look we are going
to warm them because we have influence
we have a body which is actually looking
for the privacy issues and we are going
to warn them that we are actually using
cookie Dania so you take and try to
create a profile of the individual
machine obscenity no no the the person
we don't care about the machine you're
binding IDs to machines not to
information or you're required on person
so the IP address isn't adequate so you
look at the browser and look at
characteristics of the browser and any
other piece of information you have to
try to isolate each individual user yeah
yeah Mauro mostly yeah such a challenge
oh yeah well that's a full-time job
send me about it that's my job and I'm
losing my hair's so it's very
complicated because because one of the
thing is I will come back to that later
but media are quite adverse to
technology they did not invest in
technology most of them I was kind of
suspicious approach to technology and it
was it's really hard time to actually
convince them but I'm very lucky because
in my company we have
executive team that understood from the
outset the importance of investing in
technology investing in such technology
of revenue comes from advertising in
other words you can raise APU by 10% by
raising prices
yeah actually well I think they're right
there Rose of the price of the the price
of the copy of the the price of the
physical newspaper newspapers such as
the New York Times is a pretty expensive
newspaper or printed but pretty
expensive what I've read is they're not
making any money on the print they're
actually losing money on yeah whose name
for itself distribution to 15 apples no
wine I just care where do the paper
completely
oh that's missing we're sure it's done
yeah it really bad fertilizing and just
raise the APU and provide a quality
product yeah it pertains to the
importance of paper because the paper
especially for the advertising community
gives some kind of snack use I mean that
you won't be able to perform as good as
the New York time is doing without the
paper that point number one point number
two you will always have a substrate of
base of people who might be willing to
pay for the paper at almost any price so
that's why they bundle actually the
Sunday edition was the online edition so
they can keep up the illusion of many
people reading the Sunday edition on a
Sunday to make a lot of money on the
paper advertiser
yeah there is another reason to that is
they basically make grossly speaking
half of their advertising revenue from
on Sunday so I mean that'll capacity of
the American market we don't have such
kind of stuff in France and fortunately
science yeah basically described a
system which took data and wrote
articles and did a pretty good job of it
and of course the the particular and
data that could be used would be the
news article information plus
information
about your your profile so the articles
which you would approve of could be
generated and the the acceptance of
those articles by by you and make the
CRM for ads perhaps somewhat better is
this something that you're going for
well I hope not because I think my job
is is difficult enough with writing
people ourselves so so I don't think it
might be a possibility but you know I
mean recent experience have shown that
content farms and stuff like that it's
not perform very well and well
it's totally contrary to the idea of
assigning value to the news my original
reporting original analysis and stuff so
since more and more content is consumed
through apps how does this shift to the
F word jeopardize your effort to collect
data oh that's a good that's an
interesting that's an interesting
question it pertains to our strategy we
tend to believe that Apps is kind of
transitional for us for the for the
media because technically speaking we
don't need that much apps because Apps
is wonderful when you need powerful
rendering engines for games for graphics
intensive application and stuff which is
not the case for a media that's why we
would like very much to develop web apps
because web apps you can drop cookies
you can profile your people and so on
it's not closed gate gated stuff and
like and like apps so we might actually
we're going to roll out a set of apps
next month but we are going to roll out
a first better version of web apps
because we want to learn web apps in
order to ensure proper transition for
maps to web apps it might take a while
that we might end
there sir so news has changed mm-hmm
when there was just print you had two
opportunities the day to find out what
happened what television came on you
suddenly had the breaking news thing now
you've got a mobile device and you can
get the sensation you know the immediacy
happening so news is now the sensation
of what's happening now which everybody
one needs to know is it's just this
humanistic and the analysis which is why
it happened what's going on behind it
what's the background which is why you
typically go typically go to magazines
you know yeah you go you go to the
deeper thing which so two questions
have you considered crowdsourcing the
sensation aspect because there's lots of
Twitter feeds and stuff like that and
you know why pay reporters to be in the
field when you've got a thousand readers
and somebody eles reliability I think
well okay
crowdsourcing seems like like one angle
you're not talking about second one is
have you thought about flow through you
thought about letting the advertisers
hey the consumers you know why do you
keep all the advertising money and not
let your readers get a little chunk of
that you know to build loyalty to your
yeah to say you know me because yeah it
does get to invent I mean my the
literacy in interesting path but it
might be a bit complicated I'm afraid
but I understand your point here that's
what you're trying to fund the analysis
yeah right you can't you're not gonna
win against the sensation stuff you know
yeah we might we might win because at
some point I mean the history of the
press is that you are high value high
audience stories which are subsidizing
low audience stuff which is necessary to
up for example I mean with your bar yeah
but we need to keep on that because we
need to report on complicated things
when we report about the EU
for in Japan to Europe European
community issues which are extremely
important for a country year like
friends it is high and sexy as you can
imagine of course compared to a people
story
compared to kind of sensational story
but if we need to bundle the whole the
whole to in order to be able to produce
the EU story which is very important so
I need to go a little bit faster so just
look but but as Craigslist demonstrated
you cannot maintain a bundle great so
let's took away all the advertising room
yeah he's cost funny shows quite quite a
bit so up so the bundle can't if you
rely on the bundle that's dead it's
gonna die TMZ is gonna beat you to
Michael Jackson yeah but if we unbond
all the stuff we will die anyway so we
prefer to give the bundle for you okay
go ahead just to go back to your your
cookies is this strategy the same one
that is being used by online retailers
the big Amazon problem yes yeah actually
them they are like yours away from us in
many many ways yes basically if you take
for example the the relevancy of the
recommendation and gin by Amazon I mean
we are decades behind that okay so is
what is your strategy similar to them in
that field maybe I don't know exactly
I'm not familiar with the profiling
Amazon is doing sir try a question more
directly can't reduce paper business
avoid without advertising do you have to
have an advertising model depends on the
size and it says of the paper boy no no
the New York Times wouldn't be able to
survive without ties no they were not
divided no no they I mean considering
the site of the New York Times
considering the fact that they have 1200
journalists and it cost them 200
millions per year to produce their stuff
just to produce the news they won't be
able to to considering the fact that the
digital of it that digital subscribers
brings only less than a million million
dollars they won't be they would need
advertising
I lead to mood tumour little bit I will
try to go fast the thing is what we
consider is we we need to shift from a
notion of publications vertical
publication to a notion of platform
these people guys here we consider them
as aggregators basically the audience is
there and we need to attack them through
api's we need to attack them through
social and this is the application and
web apps we are having currently at
least Co we need to serve them with
different mode different vectors that
will fit their needs and preferences we
will have web site mobile sites web apps
native apps and home the all of them
will be interconnected that's the that's
the idea the first point is
understanding technology we are
basically in a business in which now
it's necessary to invest and to master
data search web optimization in order to
a fast content content generation to
some extent maybe not to the extent of
narrative science with application web
application it's now it's a technology
driven business very few people and just
understand that actually the New York
Times did understand them and several in
the United States does so unfortunately
we did this we left did this field to
other if you consider this application
none of them has been invented by a
publisher to the point that some of them
are buying site has been purchased by
CNN pulse has been purchased not by a
maniac a media company but but by a
social network which makes LinkedIn a
competitor to our business we need to
reinvent the corporate media Louis work
in the chief producer Fischer for Forbes
say mention that two things important to
me
he put his company on a start mode
completely different approach and
considered that is competitor
much broader than the other other
publisher and I think is totally right
by the way the digital revenue for
Forbes represent now accounts for 50% of
the total and they have a gross of
almost 20% on a year-to-year basis so we
we big overhaul is required this was the
first version of the multimedia reporter
I'm a bit severe because we have changed
a bit and and media companies are quite
modern now but we need more linear
organization less centralized
organization more agile more tolerance
for fair experiment means that this is a
thing I I learn by writing and talking
to tech people is that they do have this
test and learn approach they encourage
failure to some point they are not
deterred by failure by the perspective
of a failure
we need more technical people people
able to understand all of the
integration of our business basically we
list we need less memo and more proto
that's very important stuff and in the
end we need to call this guy Charles
Darwin in order to preserve the idea of
this man because in the end it's a
matter of democracy thank you so I want
to talk to you about the difference
between you have New York Times used a
lot of New York Times and your
publications more of a national
publication and the difference between
that and your local newspaper because I
mean the New York Times can draw on a on
the audience's face in the
english-speaking world and China too
they have a Chinese you know so they can
have they can get a million you know
almost a million paid subscribers
whereas if you're in a town of only a
million people and you try to get enough
to bug boost that up you're not going to
get there well I would say depends on
the value proposition if you are able to
to to tell your readers
in your town that what you are proposing
them in terms of news coverage is
absolutely unique and they won't find
anything else elsewhere if you are not
in the comedy commodity news if you are
in the value-added news you might have a
way to of these people paid for and
actually there is plenty of example of
American newspaper who are extremely
harsh extremely severe in their approach
to pay world I mean they are the numbers
are small but people have no choice but
paying online and forced some of them it
works but of course it works better for
large organization but and you're right
in the sense that the English language
helped quite a bit
the New York Times they have something
like 40 million movies per month 13
million movies domestically so we are in
the business in which the year the the
winners takes all the biggest you are
the more chance you have to lady you
think you have a question yeah so when
cable TV first entered and also drew
eight viewers from broadcast um ad rates
went down for broadcast yeah but
eventually the ad rates rebounded
because even though the total amount of
people watching a broadcast show went
down in absolute terms it was still a
huge market it was still like sort of
the easiest way to reach fortune million
viewers um so I guess I'm wondering if
you get the sense that print advertising
might also sort of enjoy that same kind
of rebound where you might have fewer
people overall looking at newspapers in
the printed form but it's still the only
place you could you know have a huge ad
or reach that large audience well
actually there is another mechanism I
didn't mention about the the dismissal
of advertising which is the time spent
on all various media
when you compare the time spent of on
the web versus the time spent on on on
print you will see that the time spent
on the web is much bigger but they're
the allocation they add spending what
brains are spending on it is much
smaller which is totally the contrary on
the print prints small viewership in
terms of time allocation but high
spending so the mechanism will offset
the stuff and it's machism which is
going to actually withdraw some
investment for the prints so
mechanically the print advertising is
about to dry up furthermore I don't know
if it doesn't squirt here question maybe
I hope no I don't think so no what's the
competition for advertising is so huge
now that we might is no longer a
zero-sum game sir
you talk about building essentially a
user model over time of people why
aren't you so when I come to your site
for the first time you know nothing yeah
I know the ad networks have inverted
that in some sense no matter where I go
the ad network knows what to do for me
yeah so why aren't you letting them
provide you the the personalization so
the first time I show up completely
personalized for me oh it's simply
because they sell they sell we try not
selling them premium at the advertising
space why not buy from them
personalization that you're that you're
trying to build oh yeah you don't better
out of it you mean yeah actually that's
a good question because you have a
growing number of companies which are
going to create some kind of marketplace
for data so we might be able to buy
profile at some part but
actually we believe it's much more
valuable to build our own profile
because we are actually our view is that
just to give you very basic ideas -
PayPal is eco they do have currently
four million UVs counted by Nielsen
which is more or less but never
mind
four million movies the largest
newspaper in France they hide there in
the neighborhood of 11 million the
target group we are aiming at in France
is a little bit than five million people
there are people which are interesting
for us for many reasons
business manager executive students and
stuff so we have a chunk of kind of
limited target group and if we want to
pursue a raise to 10 million uvs per
month we will lose in terms of
qualification of these people and the
whole idea is actually to find a way to
manage some kind of a scientists in
order to get more value at some point we
will stop growing our audience and we
won't seek any further growth but the
idea that in the meantime we might be
able to extract much more value for our
stock of readers that's why that's our
reasoning to put hard figures on it I
think it would be fair to to assign to
us an objective of maintaining our 10
euros of CPM but I think I think it was
better to push it and to actually
increase the gap between general news
general information news paper wearing
the you who are in the lower single
digits and versus us we hope we will
remain in the double digit territory
stir I'm sorry
found fascinating Tolkien I just got to
pessimistic thoughts for you I mean your
last sort of shopping list your wish
list yeah of the property's a newspaper
needs it needs to survive in a modern
environment it didn't in any way trade
on any special feature that a new
newspapers have compared to any other
sector that could have been a wish list
of what a university needs to do to
survive in the modern environment or
what a car manufacturer needs to do no
we did we need more techies we need to
be more agile it was there was nothing
in it that you as well you could trade
off compared to the sectors that are
taking revenue away from you the other
pessimistic thought is I mean I love it
include your analysis so you know there
are the aggregators of different types
and they're taking out advertising
revenue away from newspapers that made
very good sense to me but when I look at
the different types of success like
engagement these month these monsters
seem to me at the moment to be on a
growth curve I don't see a reason why I
no see a move that you can make that
take some advantage of newspaper this
then is going to slow Google or Amazon
or some of these other monster
alligators down well I don't see well
first of all I don't see Google as
either as a competitor but I don't think
Google as much as danger I mean the
press has a complex relationship with
Google because because a special
inference we yell about Google but
Google brings us a lot of values because
we have some some newspaper online
newspapers that they depend on Google up
to 40% of their traffic means that on
one one hand we will criticize Google
for its power and stuff on the other
hand we will spend huge amount of money
at doing SEO and CM in order to please
Google there is another danger though I
didn't mention that which are the the
the hardcore aggregators
let me mention two of them Business
Insider or their things and post these
are clever companies
run by people hard work people and small
people but the problem is I did the
exercise one time I took a stories by
vanity fair' this stories by my own
assessment must have cost something like
fifty thousand dollars to report all
together the guy spent months and months
on the story and stuff the story on the
vanity fair-- come generate something
like 30 comments the same story was on
the effington post and there are 300
words kind of condensate of the story
resume summary sorry and it generates
600 comments race means that you have a
value which is taken for free because of
course the the Athenian poster story was
absolutely clear on copyrights and they
mentioned the sort they link back and so
on and so forth there with that we are
fairly clean but they actually took the
value hijack the value away from Vanity
Fair so there is two analyzes either the
official post clever are extremely
people are extremely clever which is the
case or the vanity where people are a
bit damp as far as digital strategy is
concerned I'll let you draw your own
conclusion scarcity other people would I
believe disgust yes value as long as you
manage your own scarcity I mean that if
you are able to actually restrict the
number of pages you are going to put
your atom and you if you are able to
concentrate the incoming investment of
the advertising community on the most
valuable stuff and if you decide that
you won't sell to any ad networks which
will resell you your
for less than a dollar of CPM I think
you're creating some value but you have
to have unique content that's the issue
if if you make this montage with some
kind of commodity news that you can find
everywhere else then it won't work you
need to preserve your owning your
uniqueness you need to have a new media
outlet some stuff that won't be
available anywhere else that's that's
the idea yeah but personally that's an
interesting question personally I would
prevent the effington path of of taking
back my stories and it doesn't work that
way because actually it was candidly
told by people from their fintan post
they are a basically explaining how it
works there they're receiving calls from
the New York Times saying okay we have
this stuff you should take back and
backlink to us so the newspaper industry
and the other print online print
industry if you will online news
industry is actually selling itself you
know and I think it's a big mistake I
think we need to be much more radical
than we are so you have a system which
gathers information about people there
are strong laws and France yeah privacy
and that sort of thing much stronger
than here yeah to what extent is that
constraint
well we we're not we first of all our
lawyers are currently working around
this but we believe we are sure that we
might be remaining the boundaries of the
other French laws because the French
laws say that you can collect stuff but
you have to declare it and you have to
inform your people your audience then
actually you are going to collect some
information you have to detail the
information yet that you are about to
collect and you have to give them a way
to the you have to give provide them a
possibility to opt out of your systems
so
it will and we're going to be very
careful with that because we don't
resale our data we don't share them
because we know that if someone
subscribed to or goes to our website and
actually find itself couple of weeks
months later deluged by unwanted mail
and stuff and if they find a way to
actually link this deluge to us it would
be a really killer stuff for our
business so we are going to be extremely
careful with that so I'm in the news
industry like you are in Europe and
don't you sing since it's so costly for
us to produce news and you give the
example of the New York Times but there
will be digital-only companies that will
produce unique content and are the
economies of the internet much more
cheaper like models over here feature a
further explanation and simply pick
experts on the field
yeah like 25 experts on the 49ers in San
Francisco and let them report Sunday for
Sunday and simply pay them into the
vanity it was recognition everything
that do a much better job and then any
professional journalist actually could
do on the 49ers that that could be the
possibility possibility for the 49ers
that won't be a possibility for a
financial investigation regarding Wall
Street abuse that won't be a possibility
for covering a foreign conflict that
won't be a possibility to actually make
an in-depth profile of the person AF
brothers yeah your model is not
contradictory to mine and actually we
should we as a whole we should not
insulate ourselves saying we are just
doing value-added news we ignoring the
rest and you write in the sense that we
should also consider crowdsourcing and
stuff as you just mentioned they are not
contradictory as long as we keep some
part of kind of code or sanitaire about
our uniqueness I think that's a key
element
sir so big picture this is a people were
working on alternate ways of funding
news sources I mean this advertising is
I hate it you hate it yeah yeah I'd be
really well you like it you light it in
print and you in order to print no no
justjust don't worry your question so
does the street sir anything equivalent
to curious or NPR yes we direction we
have web public from the broadcast stuff
the model I'm I'm looking more with a
great deal of interest I wrote a story
about it is probably can in the u.s.
probably is a very interesting model but
it sounds something unique that you
won't find in many countries which is
philanthropy funded kind of stuff based
on various syndication that will help to
fund the stuff without an agenda and I
think it's pretty unique to the family
trust to a funder ProPublica they
basically don't have an agenda they went
to poor stagger the former editor of The
Wall Street Journal and they say guy
we're going to fund you the first years
of your operations but you are going to
do great journalism investigative
reporting socially engaging stories in
society important stories and that's the
whole envelope for instance in France if
you have so if we might have some
billionaires willing to sustain such
kind of stuff we might have someone who
might be willing to put its agenda on it
so it's pretty unique model but I don't
believe that much that we could have
publicly are funded journalism by the
way in France I mean the 10% of the
revenue of the actual newspaper in
France is coming from public subsidies
which i think is totally dangerous call
danger
and a Berlusconi Murdock model will
spread they simply take over the
universe like you know that's brother's
gonna bottle doing in Europe
everybody's got he's got Italy yeah well
you've basically failed the two to do
that in France so he launched and lunch
and then he closed was part of a over
oven major television network which
lasted a few years and yeah this guy but
this guy was kind of it was kind of
dangerous yeah he recently had an agenda
Annie
he's TV content was extremely cheap and
stuff so well seems to be growing
Murdoch is growing but Murdoch is
growing in a fairly old-fashioned way I
would say there is no much digital
property that Murdoch was successfully I
mean The Wall Street Journal is a great
newspaper interpret newspaper online but
it's it's great newspaper because it was
a great newspaper very online very on
early days yeah foxy Dennis yeah apropos
to your hotel we had an email an email
from who proposed a different model
he believes of course that advertising
is the root of all evil and probably
should be eliminated and that content
should be paid for by the user so he
suggested that things be sold
essentially in small units probably not
words more like paragraphs I think you
know using the mechanism very much like
Ted Nelson's
trans copyright mechanism and that users
would by their access by paying in
pinpoints unreasonable structure
innocence because it it basically gives
you access to everything have a theme
which
perhaps could be made very small the
logistics of course are somewhat
significant but not insurmountable and
it is a different a totally different
model from what we have today it takes
the commercial side of things out
totally yeah
not certainties my job stuff well I have
some prevention about about it for
several reasons first of all as a
citizen I'm a bit allergic with the
notion of an anonymous money that's
point number one but let's forget about
it let's just consider the the business
policy suggest we need recurrence we
need recurring models point number one
point number two we need to establish a
relationship with our readers that's a
very important part and by doing so we
might be extremely sensitive to the to
the wave of the news cycle mean that we
won't sell that much word phrase
paragraph and stuff in a slow day slow
week slow month news cycle but we will
fare much better and on high news cycle
so it might have two consequences the
first one is that we will be really
depending on the news which is by a
sense unpredictable and the other
consequences might be that some news
outlet might be tempted to create their
own news which I mean to make things
foamy as the same friends you know so we
think it might be a bit dangerous
because well yeah Google antitrust
supplement in Europe make any difference
I'm sorry well the Google I don't think
it does make a difference to us well
frankly as long as Google is not
deciding to to ensure original news
reporting kind of stuff it doesn't make
any difference the only thing in which
Google is affecting us is the the
ability to act as a kind of a black hole
for the advertising revenue since
the search is still growing as the
display is less growing in the part of
the display that Google is actually
capturing is fairly significant so sorry
you didn't have an opportunity and the
lady you will have the last word okay so
related to the topic of users disliking
ads back when web ads and I guess they
still are kind of popular users decided
sort of sudden users anyway I don't know
what percentage decided to fight back by
installing these things called adblock
ID blocking yeah that's right the most
downloaded extension of Firefox I'm
wondering did that play a role in any of
the downturn of web ads or was that was
that even a noticeable impact it didn't
doesn't have a noticeable impact
I am I understand your question because
I as much I'm able to check it I am but
it doesn't have any impact but I think
it's a sign it's a signal I'm sorry we
we we should not ignore it miss and I
think it will but I I take it those
intermediaries existed in the wind you
know when it was print only right so
there I know there were much less for
the print yeah so I guess what I was
wondering was with the technological
tools you were talking about is that an
opportunity for an area of opportunity
for you you know sort of to
disintermediate that relationship with
advertisers or do you think that a lot
of those innovators sprang up in the
electronic well there must have been
sprung up yeah oh yeah yeah definitely I
mean compared to the I've been in the
news business for quite a while now and
compared to the to the early the early
days of the print only business there is
much more intermediaries at this time
you have these whole people working on
data reselling the remnant and
advertising and stuff and which did not
exist at the printer era
so so that's
much more fragmented market and and this
intermediaries are capturing great deal
of value a thing
you